hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast at
ha ha ha just check it in on you saying
are you doing during these strange times
is this the new normal I I don't know
how you guys do it god bless you if
you're still [ __ ] watching TV and
listening to people saying things like
that as we adjust to the new normal I
ain't no one [ __ ] person says it and
then everybody says it and nobody gets
called out for being a hack
you know stand-up comic if I go up and I
go [ __ ] do somebody else's joke I'm a
goddamn thief
these [ __ ] [ __ ] lazy ass
journalists all say in the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] another favorite of mine oh I love
this one is when when people when people
say this this is this oh this territory
that's what gets me when when people
[ __ ] go you know this has been
especially hard for me right immediately
let's just grab that camera lens point
it right at your sister right this has
been especially difficult for me because
I'm such a social person can you [ __ ]
believe that there's people out there
saying that this has been especially
difficult for me because I'm such a
social person you're used to going to
cappuccino cupcake down the street and
[ __ ] dumping you morning on somebody
it's been especially hard for me because
I'm such a social person I was actually
joking with a buddy of mine say you know
as we stood right next to each other
[ __ ] spitting and one of those no we
were on the phone I [ __ ] I was saying
people who say you know because I'm such
a social person what they really are
upset about
it's not that other people are dying not
that people are struggling not that
small businesses are trying desperately
to stay afloat that's not what they're
upset about they're upset that this
virus stole attention from them you know
even if they could get together with
their friends the top of a conversation
is not gonna be that person it's gonna
be Cove in 19 and they're it's
especially hard for me jesus [ __ ]
christ sitting in a house with a flat or
apartment whatever a flat-screen TV a
[ __ ] Gameboy it's especially hard for
me you know I heard maybe two or three
people say that and then I just acted
like a third of the population did and
that is the secret behind my formula
[ __ ] fly in here the [ __ ] virus do
you have you [ __ ]
you know you know I got all this
somebody's gonna be like you know it's
crazy is you look at these mosquitos
it's right they'll find some guy rolling
around and like human and dog [ __ ] and
being like what in the [ __ ] are you
doing I'm trying to get my immunity up
this is the mosquito diet see mosquitoes
are on all kinds of [ __ ] all day long
notice they transfer viruses but they
never seem to get one and then these
people remember those people they were
like [ __ ] drinking butter you know
what I mean and it [ __ ] putting
crumbled cigarettes and then [ __ ]
raisin brand you've been lied to man
it's all alive
oh yeah right so um anyway uh I know
what the [ __ ] I was talking about it's
gonna be the new thing there's gonna be
some sort of new it'll somehow be
connected with CrossFit is there'll be
some new I'm keeping my immune system
I'm alkaline somehow that will somehow
combine with dog [ __ ] and of course if
you do it then if you're in CrossFit
you'll then have to run down the street
with the dog [ __ ] bag pass everybody
eating so everybody can know that you're
on the alkaline mosquito immunity
[ __ ] CrossFit thing all right maybe
I'm going a little nuts here [ __ ]
sitting around I don't know I just took
the family out for a drive for the first
time in like four days I literally left
my block for the first time in like four
days right I'm just [ __ ] doing what
people say right so we need bananas
right so I got my co vid mask and I only
have one glove though all right my wife
dropped the [ __ ] ball I only got one
glove so now I got to walk into this
[ __ ] grocery steal it right so it's
like all right so I'll hold the baggy
bag with my free hand and then the
Michael Jackson glove hand is gonna grab
all the [ __ ] right and put it in the bag
so that's what I did the best I could
all right then before I got in the car
she spritz my [ __ ] hand I threw out
the glove okay it's a [ __ ] off all right
I'm doing I can't this is what kills me
go to the grocery store right you go
well they sell the food right and
everybody's got masam which is great but
you're still supposed to try to stay six
feet apart people are they're not
[ __ ] doing it right and then they
literally had X's on the floor to where
you're supposed to stand while you're
waiting for your turn to pay for your
[ __ ] food it's right there that
they're right [ __ ] there people sorta
on it lingering near it
I'm it's like they literally have the
answers to the test and they're still
failing I just I don't I am losing a lot
of empathy for people you know post this
is what I'm gonna come out of the
[ __ ] thing and when I listen to
somebody bitching about their [ __ ]
career or how they got passed over and
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
in my head I'm gonna be like you know
this is a great [ __ ] chance this is
one of these [ __ ] jerk-offs that if
you paint a [ __ ] X on the floor and
tell them to go stand there that's all
they need to do until called upon
they can't even [ __ ] do that answers
to the test
still flunking although I was supposed
to have well that sister have masked
didn't say they have gloves so I kind of
[ __ ] up - I had one bare hand so maybe
maybe they were looking at me like you
know this [ __ ] guy you know just cuz
you're standing on an X you know you got
a bare hand there I mean you know who
knows maybe you had that hand up some
bats ass on a trip to China right and
then you got you some dumplings you know
and the virus walked down the [ __ ]
chopsticks there and then and then maybe
maybe your patient number one maybe
you're a carrier so anyway we drove
around we had a good [ __ ] time
no daughter is such a friggin sweetheart
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous she's
everything I'm not she's emotionally
she's totally connected to her emotions
she watches like you know the [ __ ] that
I have on the other day oh I was
flipping through the channels I was
watching that Kirk Gibson Dodgers verse
the A's game what a [ __ ] game Vin
Scully and [ __ ] joe gergiolla I
remember as a kid I was just like man if
your team is playing and joe gergiolla
is doing the [ __ ] color on it like
you're in the big time this is a big
time baseball game it's not the local
guys anymore we're getting the national
guys so just hearing his voice was
awesome and rest his soul and I was
watching that game and then she came in
you know dad I want you to play with me
and I was wiped out right so I was just
like all right you know I'm finishing up
this [ __ ] script I think I'm working
harder now than I did what why are you
being with your kid
24/7 is [ __ ] harder than telling
jokes believe me
not that you needed to know that but I
will reiterate it not that you didn't
already know that I mean so I'm flipping
through the channels to try and find
something and then I see the it's the
end of The Wizard of Oz so I put it on
and it's spoiler alert it's the part
where there's some [ __ ] weird I want
a goddamn hot air balloon and they
[ __ ] leave and then she's finally
gonna [ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ]
she's saying goodbye to the the
Scarecrow the oil man and the [ __ ] the
Tin Man and the [ __ ] the lion right
and she's all sad and everything and my
daughter three years old is watching it
and she's watching this interaction she
just goes oh oh she misses them I was
just like you know I'm 51 and I still
can't [ __ ] do that do you know when I
watch TV and I see people crying I start
laughing not even like in a mean way
that is just my natural unless it's some
real sad [ __ ] then I'll actually tear up
and probably start crying like a little
girl but like if it's just like I don't
know what you know this damn coulvet
virus my massage fell down out front
store my dad put that up and I'll just
start [ __ ] laughing you know not that
I'm happy that that happened but this I
don't know I don't know why I don't know
why I [ __ ] do it
if you guys ever saw a video of me
watching the [ __ ] news you would
think I was one of the worst human
beings yeah ask my wife she does it all
the time she goes what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
that's I think I don't know I feel bad
I'll [ __ ] go do a benefit for that
guys sign but when he's standing out
there crying in the rain and the signs
all [ __ ] up it's just it's it makes me
laugh I'm sorry that happened if I could
help out I will all right but if you're
gonna [ __ ] it you know when you're
telling the story I'm gonna laugh though
I'm sorry all right I keep
[ __ ] shutting my goddam recorder off
its gonna add another eight seconds when
I go to splice it together whatever what
the [ __ ] do you want from me so I'm
riding around my lovely wife and my
beautiful daughter right and you know my
wife she listens to all the young
people's [ __ ] right so I'm listening to
this song a song by Drake right and he's
like oh oh put in line is literally
there's how much about can't I am I
couldn't get through the song after the
first line
he was like working on the weekend like
usual and I'm immediately thinking like
and I looked I go that sounds like Drake
and I looked and it said drinking I'm
thinking like doesn't this guy work for
himself it's like dude you're
self-employed you know if you don't want
to work on the weekend don't work on the
weekend but if you decide to work on the
weekend I don't hear you [ __ ]
bitching about it working on the weekend
like usual what is the deal with rappers
always telling me how [ __ ] hard
they're working the [ __ ] am i doing
laying around jesus [ __ ] christ
dawn 24/7 365 money Never Sleeps working
on the weekend like usual yes welcome to
being successful your phone your you're
going to be busy the [ __ ] did you think
you were gonna be doing making all this
money and then laying around you can't
can't [ __ ] do it Jesus Christ working
on the weekend like usually this [ __ ]
people out there fighting wars right now
whatever whatever it probably means
something else so then I went home and
then Mia showed me the video and he's on
a garbage truck working on a weekend
like yo-yo and he gets off and I'm picky
well he's not a garbage collector and
then he worked at a cell phone so oh is
this like a workingman song alright then
I then and then my apologies to Drake my
apologies alright and I would love to
blame that on the pandemic but I'm gonna
have to take it myself that I would have
been a [ __ ] about the first line of
song you know even if there wasn't a
pandemic all right what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me why can't I listen to a
song and some guy just tells me how
[ __ ] know that he's working on a
weekend like usual why why does that why
do I have to it's like I think that's
just how I was raised if you started
bitching everybody you know I remember I
had this construction job right and if
you [ __ ] [ __ ] anything you [ __ ]
complained about everybody on this site
would just suck Oh baby noises and it
was so [ __ ] funny it was so funny I I
you waiting for someone to [ __ ]
you almost wanted a [ __ ] just to hear
it I gotta move on with this [ __ ]
thing's over to them we what are you
gonna do after that the only thing you
can do walk pick this [ __ ] up and go
[ __ ] put it over there oh god I know
I've said I have to tell you guys how
much [ __ ] fun I had working in
warehouses doing landscaping even though
his [ __ ] back-breaking work it's the
[ __ ] hardest I've ever left at work
and I think even beyond hanging out with
other comedians because it wasn't that
[ __ ] morose competitiveness and
[ __ ] Groundhog Day I [ __ ] hate my
ass the blob blob was just [ __ ] I
don't know I really like blue collar
jobs where you [ __ ] you went from
site to site my favorite thing wasn't
the job it was the drive between jobs
and I'd be thinking I'm riding a car
right now getting paid this is [ __ ]
great you know I had this job I remember
I had this job washing windows people's
houses the spray bottle the [ __ ]
paper towels the rags and you [ __ ]
get up there and some people just wanted
the windows and then other people be
[ __ ] cheap [ __ ] and they try to be
get you get like paint off of the
[ __ ] windows and vacuum and up all
the bugs in between and say hey well
this window washers alright you got some
hard rain and some bird [ __ ] and then we
draw the line that [ __ ]
I'm not scraping paint off of your
[ __ ] windows but we did it got out
the little [ __ ] cocaine Raisa
I told this story before remember that
we work for this [ __ ] lady and oh my
god she was relentless
she had me go up the ladder like [ __ ]
three times on the same [ __ ] window
and Emma she was standing every time I'd
be like nah no I did it she got it still
is still uh they still don't know that
that I got better there I'd be like no I
went up there and as I was saying I
already went up there bye-bye and she
just got hey I swear to God it went
right to the base of my spine the first
time she did it I almost started
laughing and I was like I I'll go back
up this so I went back up the ladder and
I'm [ __ ] up they're wiping and I'm
like it's not coming off it's paint I
got paper towels in a rag this is like
man she's like [ __ ] think so I come
back down I tell her the thing she's
there in my face
so she's [ __ ] bitching at me and I
look at my boss and he's got a
shit-eating grin on his face and kind of
does the half now I just go back up the
ladder make her [ __ ] happy so I go
back up there and I got a little razor
I'm trying to scrape this [ __ ] thing
off and this I must fell off the ladder
she [ __ ] comes walking into the right
I know she's gone back into the house
and she came walking up to the window
that I was washing you know and I'm
looking at what's on the window so I'm
not seeing her coming in and she [ __ ]
I you know I didn't you know when you
leaned back in a chair head on those
little [ __ ] heart attacks like it cuz
was like at the top of the house and for
a second I thought I thought the house
was haunted because it was the urban
myth that there was a house in that room
that had a fire and you know one of the
key little kids couldn't get out and it
burned a silhouette of him in the
[ __ ] window and the parents were so
distraught they refused to wash the
window and I was just like yeah I don't
wanna I don't want my boys if you want
to go see it I'm like no I don't he
claimed it was true I think he's
bullshitting me but you know that was in
my [ __ ] head I got off this goddamn
ladder so I'm out there talking to
myself I don't even see her and I'm
liking this if I can't get [ __ ] [ __ ]
off
and I just hear from the other side went
oh I almost fell off the [ __ ] ladder
oh god it's funny I must have did a
thousand houses and I never [ __ ]
forgot her and I will tell you this
though god bless her because she got a
[ __ ] money's worth window washing and
I'm scraping paint you know why I'm
scraping [ __ ] paint up because you're
a tight [ __ ] and you hired an amateur
painter who just went up and do by the
way painters are the [ __ ] worst by
the way this is the thing yeah you tell
them to paint a [ __ ] room take
anything out of there you don't want
painted cuz those [ __ ] are
painting over everything
door locks window latches flat-screen
TVs they just don't give a [ __ ]
they'll paint a door they'll paint the
[ __ ] like where the [ __ ] lock
meets the latch or whatever the [ __ ] you
call they'll paint that thing right over
the goddamn thing beautiful yeah yeah
you know I have an old house beautiful
[ __ ] brass hardware where sleeps all
over the whole [ __ ] thing yeah this
is a thing I think painters are people
who were too dumb to be carpenters
plumbers you know what I mean it's it's
like coloring for an adult you know if
you want the eye and I'm not talking
about people that take a canvas right
and then they [ __ ] you know whatever
they squirt [ __ ] paint up their ass
and then squat over it and people think
oh my god what is he trying to say here
right now I'm not talking with those
people where there's some sort of
thought I just mean painters you know I
mean it's why they were always going
around the colleges trying to get kids
to go out and [ __ ] paint because it's
just like just take this brush and go
good all over the [ __ ] wall and you
know something if you're a [ __ ]
painter I want you to defend yourself go
ahead and write in this [ __ ] podcast
I you guys are the [ __ ] dopes they'll
[ __ ] but you see them when you see
them they [ __ ] me they got more paint on
them and they got on the [ __ ] wall
big blotch of paint and they're [ __ ]
overgrown eyebrow they are the [ __ ]
dopes of the trade you know but I bet
like anything I bet if there's anything
there's the Richard Pryor of [ __ ]
house painters
and there's not a [ __ ] goddamn drop
on any of the [ __ ] windows I think
that that's what annoyed me the most
that I was doing somebody else's [ __ ]
job what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
paints a house gets paint on a window
and doesn't wipe it off just leaves you
know what kind of an [ __ ] a [ __ ]
painter all right okay that ought to get
me some emails okay first of all I have
you know on behalf of all painters you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about you bald redheaded freckles [ __ ]
all right I got the blue tape all over
the place all right oh you could be
literally sitting in the middle room I
could be there blindfolded with the
[ __ ] spray gun I still wouldn't get a
[ __ ] drop I won't have some painters
talk some [ __ ] okay cuz as a right now I
think you guys the [ __ ] dopes of the
trade okay you you want to be an
electrician those are the mathletes of
the trade all right
then the next one the good shits you
know that we're in high math did all
right you know played a little bit of
sports those are the carpenters all
right and then the animals single-parent
house not enough food in the fridge they
are the plumbers under the sink just
looking for a piece of bread they all
[ __ ] childhood then they got
fascinated with the pipes that's what it
was that's what it was
they lived in squalor and they're not
afraid of human [ __ ] there I think I
broke down the trades and heavy machine
operators are just [ __ ] lazy they
just want to sit there getting paid why
am I doing this
I don't know I'm [ __ ] bored listen I
just want to apologize to anybody who
works with their hands I didn't mean it
in an offensive way it's a comedy
podcast I was just trying to [ __ ]
alright or is he just sent me a thing
what the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
Oh what the [ __ ]
this Jesus Christ he thinks this is an
actual person his [ __ ] phone get the
hacked um anyway what am i up to yet
Jesus Christ this 21 minutes right there
you know it's time to do a little bit of
advertisement but I don't have the
advertising yet so I'm just gonna do a
little pause here while the advertising
is read okay here we go a little bit a
little advertising here one read one
read rake on everybody race on RA Y Co n
you know whether you're working from
home or working on your fitness you want
what you're listening to to be what
you're listening to not what your
personal year roommates your neighbors
your wife your kids whatever a listening
to you want to hear what you want to
hear right everyone needs a great pair
of wireless earbuds but alright but
before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
the wireless earbuds from rake on your
already no rake on earbuds start at
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market I
didn't know that and they sound just as
amazing as the other top audio brands
you know the newest model the everyday e
25 earbuds are the best ones yet with
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit rate cons wireless
earbuds are also so comfortable perfect
for conference calls or binging on
podcasts unlike some of the other
wireless options rake on ear bugs are
both stylish and discreet with no
dangling wires or stems to distract
anyone during video calls now's the time
to get the latest and greatest from race
on recon get 15% off your order at buy
rake on comm slash bird that's by rake
on.com slash bar for 15% off rake on
wireless earbuds
that's Bui RA Y Co n comm / BER that's
great that just as good as all the top
brands they're they're half the price
and you get in 15% off that so fifty per
and fifty at 65% off and if you like me
you're gonna lose them anyway so why the
[ __ ] buy a really expensive pair when
the other one sound just as good for
half the price plus 15% off alright
that's it go to buy rate Khan Khan slash
bar I'm back alright what else did I
want to talk about there was some
[ __ ] story I wanted to tell you that
I've pissed off everybody in the trades
I'll tell you right now if it wasn't for
plumbers you'd be outside shooting in an
outhouse that was it painted
who's gonna build the outhouse all right
uh all right what have I been doing you
know I really do you know today I was
driving up in like the hills out in the
valley with my lovely family and it's a
nice clear day beautiful temperature out
here and I got to tell you something man
I [ __ ] miss flying like you [ __ ]
read about uh I [ __ ] miss it so much
I didn't realize how much it got in me I
just thought was this cool thing that I
learned how to do I actually I literally
missed I missed the Smail mr. sounds I
miss being on radio I miss being up
there solo in the tower says something
to me and I'm like I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means excitement the
excitement of I'm not gonna [ __ ] this up
no and I told you I took I flew an a
star one time and I cannot shake that
feeling every time I see a police
helicopter go over that's what they fly
every time I see I follow him on
Instagram all these helicopter things
and whenever I see it that is it's not
the sexiest look in helicopter but it's
the coolest one that I've flown I never
flew the [ __ ] the other way I've
talked about this [ __ ] but I'm
really really missing that [ __ ] other
than that I just been trying to eat
whale staying home I got one for you man
I've just been making these house salads
like you know I'm really [ __ ] into
you know obviously trying
to waste food which is something you
know III think I've been doing up until
this point in my life like just throwing
[ __ ] just goes bad so I've kind of
conquered the whole veggie going bad
thing you know you just get a giant head
of lettuce whatever you like you chop
that [ __ ] up and whatever looks like
it only has a couple days left you chop
that up and you throw it the [ __ ]
salad and then for lunch you have that
salad and I just put a little bit of
olive oil and some [ __ ] lemon juice
give that thing a little [ __ ] toss
over there hang on one second Nate Craig
hey I am on my podcast right now I got
you on speaker can I can I call you back
after you say hello to the listeners
that's right okay and thank you for all
the hockey highlights you've been
sending me during this thing I know
you've always been there for me man I'll
call you in a few minutes
that's he yeah he's been just sending me
all this Connor McDavid [ __ ] and all the
way back to like Mario Lemieux and all
of this stuff
unbelievable hockey player 3 best
comedian hockey players I know
Nate Craig Steve Byrne and the goat the
goat Ian bagg
Ian [ __ ] bag
Ian bagg is like on another level he's
on he's he like Nate Craig and Steve
burn a [ __ ] amazing and like Ian bagg
is like semi-pro Canadian semi-pro and
I'm just fun to skate around I actually
looked at my hockey stuff I have not
skated oh my god I'm skated since 2015
when I first got this I ignore thing and
I'm hoping that there's a world in the
new normal where I can actually go to a
public rink skate frontwards and cross
over on one side for an hour before then
having to deal with turning around and
going the other way anyway what the [ __ ]
was I just talking about I was talking
about flying I wasn't talking about that
I was talking about all the salad and
then I put a little I just put like
after I tossed the salad there keep it
clean people with the lemon and the
olive oil a little bit of salt and
pepper then on top no olive oil no lemon
on this is I put like I chopped up like
a pear and I have that full lunch and if
you have a [ __ ] smoothie for
breakfast okay I'm gonna tell you what
your dad bought is gonna be doing right
then it's gonna be like what the [ __ ] is
going on right and then all the fat on
your [ __ ] flabby putting together a
swingset torso it's gonna start
disappearing I'll tell you right now I
would put my body at 51 gonna be 52 I
would put it up against any 48 year old
out there all right except for those
Instagram 48 year old guys who have
[ __ ] vegans and doing pull-ups and
pretend and they're walking upstairs I'm
not talking about those guys I'm just
saying if we went to a mall right now
and I walked up to any random 48 year
old dudes all right shirts off in three
two why don't we just you know like
we're gonna have a dance-off or
something like that [ __ ] I didn't dad's
home daddy's home right I'm telling you
telling you I could [ __ ] I could go
up against the average dead that's a
half a century two years short shy of
half a century and my goal by the end of
this pandemic is to be able to talk [ __ ]
to a 43 year old and watch him cower
right I wanted him to look down at the
floor mats in the SUV that he bought
that he did not want got a little weird
in the end [ __ ] do you want from me
so allegedly I guess this thing's gonna
end on May 15th
and I think that's dangerous to tell
people considering during this they
can't even stand on a [ __ ] X alright
so I almost think some misinformation
about that you know we're still not out
of the woods and Laflamme I don't mean
that I mean just scare the [ __ ] out of
people a little bit more just so they
don't [ __ ] it up in the end cuz all it
takes is one [ __ ] to go out there and
lick another bad [ __ ] before May 15th
and I know knows when we get to go
outside
all right that is all that is all that
is all I think next Monday I might be or
definitely sometime next week I'm going
to be on history hyenas the Yanis Papas
and Chrissy D podcast sorry I'm trying
to look it up here for my schedule when
the [ __ ] I'm gonna be there I think
we're gonna do it the text message is
sorry I think we're going I said I could
do it Monday hopefully it'll be on
Monday Yanis Pappas Chris DiStefano and
I'm gonna zoom in to that one and
tomorrow I'm gonna be on Bob Saget's
podcast tomorrow being Thursday which is
today all right that is it that is all
god bless you thank you for wearing a
mask and gloves two gloves unlike me and
you know and thank you for standing on
the X the other people Jesus Christ
could you put the [ __ ] effort in all
right I'm feeling good I'm feeling
positive we're all gonna [ __ ] do this
all right
I love everybody except for painters
spell kidding I'll even love painters
all right enjoy the music picked out by
the great Andrew feminists and now we
got a bonus half-hour over Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts from uh Thursday a
couple two or three years ago all right
have a great weekend you consoles see
you on Monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 13 14 15 16 April 16th 2012
what's this decade called by the way you
know last decade was called the 2000s or
the twos of the aughts
was it called the turn of the century
this one's called the teens you ever
think about that [ __ ] it was the roaring
20s it was the holy [ __ ] 30s and a let's
go get that [ __ ] half a mustache [ __ ]
40s the shifty 50s the hey man 60s right
Oh gives a [ __ ] it's um why am i yelling
you know why cuz I have no energy so I
figured I could just start screaming and
I could overcome my lack of [ __ ]
enthusiasm here well you know what I
gotta tell you something 58 59 bang
there's one minute one minute down 59 to
go it's Sunday night here in Los Angeles
and I'm leaning on a piano song there's
a divorced man at the bar
maybe he'd never got married he stares
into his drink thinking about what would
have been holy [ __ ] it's me sorry I just
sang a Twilight Zone episode um alright
what the [ __ ] am i doing it you know so
you know got this I got this new fancy
[ __ ] laptop you know and they got
this stupid [ __ ] password thing on
this thing I first of all I bought a
goddamn Mac knowing full well that the
person who finished assembling this
probably threw themselves out the window
to kill themselves only to be stopped by
those don't kill yourself Nets flung
back through the window landing back at
his station to then listen to soothing
don't kill yourself music alright so I
spend all this money on this laptop that
some [ __ ] eight year old put together
at four in the morning you know well
being beaten with the last thing he
assembled and they got this [ __ ]
password on here
I swear to God if I walk away from the
computer for [ __ ] five seconds
I gotta type it in again so I know what
you guys are saying I know what you
thinking you going bill why don't you
just go to that part of the [ __ ]
computer and maybe push it back to like
five minutes well I'll tell you why cuz
I can't [ __ ] find it that's why I
can't find it this thing should come
with a book already I have to go buy a
book I don't know I hate these [ __ ]
things I hate these goddamn things and I
have to be up tomorrow morning everybody
tomorrow morning I have to be at work
6:20 in the morning you understand me I
have a job tomorrow just like you guys
you're probably already at your job
aren't you swollen eyes from a weekend
of boozing you know trying to forget
that you had to come to that cubicle
thinking if you drank enough of them
maybe the thought of it would go away
and there you are sitting there you know
looking at all three sides of your
cubicle like I tell you something when
you spin yourself around your little
plastic staple chair you see that the
fourth wall you can walk right through
that you've walked into it why don't we
have walk out of your cubicle day one of
these days you know I want to start and
occupy I don't know what how about an
unoccupied your [ __ ] cubicle day you
know give me a [ __ ] office or don't
get me an office I'll just sit at a desk
like [ __ ] Jack Lemmon at the
beginning of the apartment you ever see
that movie it's great [ __ ] movie but
if you watch it they're all just sitting
in this whole line of desks and the
shooting the [ __ ] everybody's flirting
with each other they [ __ ] after work
they drink and they all do it in Jack
lemons apartment you know evidently that
was that was too much fun there was a
way we could somehow [ __ ] um have
them sitting near one another yet not
being able to see one another maybe then
we could be a little more efficient yeah
all right this is the podcast I have to
jump right into one somebody just wrote
hockey is like soccer bill how can you
hate on soccer and love hockey so much
dafuq they are so
similar yeah except one is played by men
the others played by girls who anytime
you brush up against them they go they
roll around on the ground for [ __ ] 20
minutes you know who else does that in
the NHL European soccer [ __ ] hockey
players the [ __ ] Swedes right the
Norwegians I don't know if there's
anything we jhin's I don't know all
those [ __ ] the sedin send deans
however you say him the [ __ ] twins up
there Jesus Christ even grazed there
[ __ ] Ben Affleck goatees from 1996
they flop around on the ice I like
soccer I think it is very similar to
hockey I just can't get over the [ __ ]
what does it say about the many a
country that they pretend to be hurt and
roll around so some guy will take a
little yellow [ __ ] card out of his
back pocket and run up to the person who
allegedly did it and just [ __ ] you
know pull it out like some sort of I
don't know FBI badge I hate how the ref
runs up to the guy who does it and Jake
hey there's the yellow card why doesn't
he just slap it out of his [ __ ] hand
this is one I'll start watching suck you
know what the thing I feel about soccer
I feel like the people in the stands are
tougher than the people on the field
it's it's really bizarre you know I
would go out on the pitch in a second my
little [ __ ] Larry Bird short shorts
and I'd run around there and brush up
against fellow men and watch him go
[ __ ] fall on the grass and roll
around hugging their knee that I didn't
hit I would do that a second as far as
standing in the crowd with those [ __ ]
crooked teeth sons of [ __ ] with a
couple of pints and some fish and chips
at him [ __ ] that I'd never do it
I haven't choked me to death with their
[ __ ] matching scarves I don't need
that all right I'm gonna tell you the
Premier League is phenomenal World Cup
soccer I love it I love it except for
the every time I start to get into it
there's that that just that shameless
flopping around flopping around they all
look like they're gonna cry the
Spaniards and the Italians they actually
get their eyes all welled up like [ __ ]
Merrill
throughout they're trying to win an
award that's what I would do you know
but if I was making films in England
that's what I would do right there
I would [ __ ] in you know
I'd cast just a soccer player those guys
can cry on cue all you gotta do is run
by him so anyway so now of course he
goes the condescending thing I don't
know if this guy's actually cuz he's
actually saying that he's into the Black
Hawks he's like Americans don't have the
attention span to watch the game that
the rest of the world plays you know I
love that I love I they just can't admit
that we don't give a [ __ ] because we we
like contact sports that's what we like
we like people smashing into one another
that's what we like and getting brain
damage and then bitching about it years
later even though they did it on purpose
because the [ __ ] assistant coach gave
him a thousand bucks to do it those are
the kinds of games that we like all
right we're ignorant and we're violent
but we do have an attention span all
right I understand it's beautiful game
phenomenal the corner kicks flying up
and over everybody grabbing their balls
on the penalty shots it's beautiful it's
a beautiful thing to watch ten guys
stand in a line cupping that junk yet
giving up their face to block this ball
you know and as always they always say
they why do they call it football they
should call it handball cuz they carry
it in their hands you know I don't know
what to tell you okay like I said I
totally respect the game I think it's a
beautiful game but when you guys get rid
of the flopping around and in borderline
crying in that game I'm all over it I'm
all over it alright but don't talk to me
about [ __ ] attention span it's
[ __ ] boring alright is that boring
it's just it's just [ __ ] it's the
flop for me I'm speaking for everybody
I'm speaking for me I can't get over the
flopping around
I like the Premier League I like
listening everybody singing the songs
the excitement of the crowd you can feel
it it matters there's history I can
totally get into it but every time I
start to get on the edge of my seat
somebody [ __ ] starts I don't know
what grabbing their anus
and you know flipping around and then
that douche runs up and [ __ ] stomps
his foot as he pulls out the car and I'm
just not into it all right you know I
like when people do that like they just
can't accept it you don't like their
sport like I tweeted something yes I did
do that and somehow maintain my
heterosexuality I tweeted something and
I said that you could watch Lord of the
Rings in the time it takes to watch the
final 58 seconds of a close NBA game
right the NBA I don't ever remember it
taking that [ __ ] long when I was
younger I used to watch hoop but you
know just like a baseball game baseball
games didn't take as long there wasn't
everybody doing a [ __ ] triple lindy
yet between every single [ __ ] pitch
stepping outside the batter vog grabbing
your dick could just in your gloves and
all that boring horseshit I put that
right up there with soccer all right
[ __ ] basketballs the same thing so I
end up I end up making fun of that [ __ ]
and somebody writes back the [ __ ] did
they write something on the effect that
you know we always make fun of that
which we don't understand you know kind
of like what you're doing saying that if
you're not admitting that soccer does is
kind of [ __ ] boring you're just gonna
say we don't have the attention span for
it you know yet somehow we can sit there
watching nine innings a boring baseball
plenty of Americans do that sir all
right do you hear that hear that sound
sir that's the sound of your argument
hitting the [ __ ] water and the
[ __ ] all right and this other [ __ ]
it they're talking about how you know
I'm making fun of basketball like I
don't understand it I totally understand
it I've been watching it for 30 [ __ ]
years
all right youngster been watching it
since 1981 okay and I just I don't know
if there's two things that made me stop
watching after the Jordan era everyone
who tried to be Jordan you know not
passing the ball trying not you know
trying to win without a big man I can do
it all myself because Michael did it and
then it took him like eight years to
figure out they weren't Michael you know
that type of [ __ ] Kobe's the only guy
I've been able to see see do it that
kind of to like the team aspect of it
that kind of left and then the end of
the [ __ ] game
just like this 58 [ __ ] you know the
worst is is when the other team has
clearly lost the [ __ ] game and they
keep calling timeouts ah Jesus Christ
just it's over [ __ ] what are you doing
you're trying to [ __ ] block that you
trying to delay their celebration you
know I don't know so I mean I still like
hoop you know our there's aspects of
soccer that I like but I I know there's
something about basketball I don't
understand why I watch this exciting
fast-paced [ __ ] game and then right
when it all matters
you slow the whole [ __ ] thing down
and I watch people take unguarded shots
to win the game it becomes golf at that
point there's nobody trying to stop you
you know instead of putting it into the
hole you [ __ ] throwing it in sort of
lobbing it in putting a nice pretty arc
on it unless you're Shaq you know I'm
second you put your [ __ ] hands over
the over your head you're above the rim
right so what do you do we try to throw
it in straight you know I think Shaq's
the only person probably has a worse
science background than I do you know
remember that [ __ ] runs telling you I
don't understand how planes fly now you
can you can have a on a cruise ship oh
you can have a [ __ ] pool on a cruise
ship you know what I mean
how do you dig a hole in to the end of
the fuselage and dump water in it and it
doesn't sink it's just [ __ ] beyond me
the only person I would say is a worse
science background than me would be Shaq
because he was in the league for almost
20 goddamn seasons and he never figured
out that hey you know maybe I need to
put an you know some sort of trajectory
on this thing is that the right word
it's unreal I mean when I was a kid and
I and you know I'm with the nerf hoop I
I knew do I need to do that
how can he be [ __ ] 9 feet tall and
not understand that stay and that my
[ __ ] voice is cracking um so anyways
yeah I got to go to work tomorrow 6:20
in the [ __ ] morning
Nia needs the car so that means I gotta
take big boy driver up the [ __ ]
driveway my [ __ ] neighbors are gonna
kill me but a quarter to 6:00 in the
morning yeah
it's the sound of my truck warming up
then it stalls its me pumping the gas
you know I'm at the top of the [ __ ]
driveway you know they gonna look out
the window with their noses all wrinkled
up it's gonna be ugly it's gonna be ugly
but I got to use it I got to tell you
something there's nothing better than
have a classic car and a [ __ ] Sunday
driving it around out here in LA you
know absolutely love it love it and
thanks to everybody who showed me where
I could go buy some parts for it I
ordered everything I need my side view
mirror's coming in so I can stop looking
over my right shoulder
all right this is the Monday morning
podcast everybody um welcome welcome if
you're new I know I'm Pope I'm picking
up like 1 or 2 listeners a week and
that's big for me because I like to grow
things small and that that small in a
very slow rate of speed all right I'm
not trying to blow up you know like all
these other people who are like like
[ __ ] motivated it's not my style I
like where I'm at I'm satisfied just
like when I was in high school I wasn't
doing well I wanted to get into a good
college but you know I started flunking
classes and I was just like well you
know what am I still eating every day
you know do I have plenty of water is
there a roof over my head when it's
raining out I'm fine why do I need to
pass these classes you need to really
lady with the really long dress
I'm still thinking of [ __ ] you you
might as well dress like a [ __ ] but
that's another subject as far as your
two years of a language I think as long
as I have the money I can do it anybody
in high school listening to this [ __ ]
thing you don't need two years of a
language to get in what you need to do
is either past two years of of a
language and get in that way and if you
don't then all you do is you just go to
a community college for a couple of
years and you prove that you can you can
work at a college level
right and then you just transfer it you
[ __ ] parachute in like the way
Clemens join the [ __ ] 1999 world
champion New York Yankees he just jumped
right in he parachuted right in right
through the Sun roof of the the limo
that they took the previous year when
they won the championship and then he
wanted that's how you do your college
career two years of a Community College
you can get a [ __ ] paper route and
pay for that goddamn tuition
all right you save all that goddamn
money you would dumber girls so they're
easier to bang they got lower self
esteem you know probably gonna swallow
it's all in the brochure and then right
when you got that you you think that you
can't wash the stink of the Community
College out of you you [ __ ] you apply
to a real school you apply to the school
that you wanted to go to you go out you
get some [ __ ] loans and then you're
in there and you know and you [ __ ]
get the same degree as Suzi smart pants
who [ __ ] learned how to sort of speak
a language in this country that you
don't need to speak another one in right
and then come graduation day you're
sitting right next to her half [ __ ]
price half price half off half off a
Notre Dame [ __ ] education I'll tell
you want to talk about a disappointment
going to the Notre Dame [ __ ] campus
all those years when they showed the
golden dome and Jesus standing there
with his arms out like oh we gonna score
here what right touchdown Jesus and all
the beautiful trees in the beautiful way
it's in the autumn leaves and all that
type of [ __ ] you're like oh my god
that's [ __ ] gorgeous that's where I
wanted to go to school you know I
already look like their mascot you know
I figure I'd show up they'd be like oh
my god it's him and I get laid you know
be like if you look like Elvis showed up
at Graceland you tell me somebody's not
gonna suck your dick if you got some
sequins on the side of your slacks I
mean these are just theories people so
anyways I finally went to the Notre Dame
campus and it is absolutely beautiful
but the surrounding [ __ ] area can be
summed up in one word oh gee
Jesus Christ
you want to talk about a [ __ ] reality
show waiting to happen the surrounding
area those are the people who were too
dumb to go beyond some [ __ ] fishing
for clams reality show you don't I mean
I should be the name of the reality show
too dumb to be on a tugboat whatever the
[ __ ] next job they're gonna show me the
real tugboat errs you know so there was
a cruise liner coming in and out we
didn't have her tires in the side of the
shut the [ __ ] up you know something I
would actually you know if I had to be
on a boat if I to work on a boat right
if I to get my little bita do it there's
no [ __ ] way I'd work on a cruise ship
because I don't like people okay and at
the top of the list of people that I
don't like are fat people sunbathing
okay you should have shame put your
[ __ ] shirt on okay and if I got a
look at that and bring you a slice of
cake at the same time there's no way I'm
not getting fired so cruise ships are
out the Navy I'm not joining the Navy
there's no [ __ ] way I'm joining the
Navy unless I'm gonna be a Navy SEAL and
I'm too much of a [ __ ] to do that all
right
but I'm not joining the Navy you know
see the world well what do I see
a bunch of [ __ ] water you know pull
into port somewhere for [ __ ] 20
minutes I don't want to do that [ __ ] the
Navy I always pictured them just singing
songs mopping up the deck or you're in a
[ __ ] sub and that's even the worst
you know what I mean I think I'd rather
go to prison than being a [ __ ]
goddamn sub under the water
all right that's where the subs aren't
they bill was thank God you described
where a sub is there's no [ __ ] way
there is no good goddamn [ __ ] way I
could survive on the sub you know those
little doorways all those douchebags Oh
what can you do down there
you know there's [ __ ] guys underneath
there for six
once I get some point you just gotta
shoot off a torpedo just to do it right
and it [ __ ] like whale shark or
something
are they endangered do they still have
periscopes on those things um what the
[ __ ] am I talking so I couldn't do that
job I wouldn't go out I want to go
fishing
because I saw a perfect storm and I read
the book and that's my reality [ __ ]
George Clooney ships going under and he
pushes himself back into it is if the
human body has the ability to [ __ ]
override your brain going I need some
air Mark Wahlberg was out I liked how
they had that nice little moment where
they were looking at you eat each other
and one of the worst storms ever
underwater in the dark in salt water no
masks on
they actually shared a moment you know I
[Laughter]
mean what I'm talking about
Oh a tugboat I could work on a tugboat
you know you get one of those peacoats
pea coats pea coats and you start
singing song oh she was half a fish how
do you find the vagina I can see your
tits what's up with [ __ ] mermaid
that's why I understood about mermaids
how do you get to the [ __ ] pootie
you know tits are right there that's all
you can do with a [ __ ] mermaid you
just get tit [ __ ] you know until they
got dry bill that [ __ ] dried out salt
on the side of your dick probably sting
after a while you know and she's looking
at you like you know I need to get back
in the water cuz started dry out yeah I
noticed
and I noticed with the chafing of either
side of the shaft this is one of the
filthiest [ __ ] podcasts I've ever
done and you know I don't give a [ __ ]
cuz I have to be up in like [ __ ]
three hours what are you doing tomorrow
bill that you have to be up um I got
jury duty
I got jury duty I don't have jury duty I
do have jury duty
I [ __ ] blew it off so next time I get
pulled over I think old Billy boys going
to jail you know kill two birds with one
stone
you know do they arrest you that's why
you know I haven't got a jury Duty's
probably stupid thing to admit right now
but I didn't you know it's trying to go
I just I'm done busy I work for myself
what am I supposed to do I have to go to
Albuquerque this weekend what do you
want from me
you know there's 40 people in a strip
mall that are depending on me to to go
there and talk about my dick you know I
would love to sit here and you know
listen to you make your points and then
listen to that guy make his point I
would you know something I would um when
I get old uh I'm already old but when I
get really old you know and I've just
pushed everybody away in my life and
it's just me and you know a couple pairs
of socks and you know some old man
underwear you know the one that has like
that
MC Hammer crotch so you could have your
old man balls hanging down to your knees
right and you a little sideways shuffle
to the to the toilet you know balls are
just sitting there in the water the only
thing to let you know you're still alive
you know everything every morning when
your old balls hit that toilet water I
think what I would do for entertainment
is I would go I would just watch trials
I've noticed that you know any time I
ever went to court he was always old
people just sitting there like knitting
and [ __ ] and it's like is that the
grandmother I I never knew I had and
it's just like it says you know this
[ __ ] just sitting here like watching me
go to [ __ ] you know or one of my
friends don't want a trial here and this
is just like entertainment for you and I
used to think it was really a [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing to do but I got to admit
that could be fun you're not required to
be there I would go to the sickest
[ __ ] trials you know murder trials I
would go to child molester trials
there's no [ __ ] actually no murder cuz
then they're gonna go through it nah I
go drug deal
I go drug dealer auto theft shoplifters
that's why I'd like to see some chick
who [ __ ] went in with this oversized
purse to try to steal a chandelier or
something I'd sit it out on those things
I mean what the [ __ ] I'm saying you guys
want to hear a commercial
wouldn't that be neat what if I sing at
this oh Christ I got a [ __ ] put my
goddamn password in unbelievable can
somebody please tell me where I go on
this stupid [ __ ] thing to change it
oh my god you go into settings and then
you hit the [ __ ] Apple keycard go
[ __ ] yourself um where are we
I [ __ ] hate computers you know I hate
about computers and some of the dumbest
people I know on the planet are really
good at him you know it's like golf was
talking about that last week the amount
of people I know that suck at all real
sports and then you they get out in the
course they can hit it straight you know
why cuz nobody's trying to stop all
right here we go
what do we got stamps.com everybody
attach copy where the hell is it
stamps.com everybody I've been talking
about this for a week this has been the
runaway hit as far as advertising goes
on my podcast everybody's getting
everybody's getting into this don't be
the last person to still be going to the
post office cuz you'd be like me I still
have a fax machine you understand that
people I still fax things I bought one
in 1999 it's a Panasonic and I stand by
it away anyways stamps.com alright this
is the deal alright we're all busy even
if you're an absolute loser you're busy
nowadays have you know what I said I I
don't have a frigging day job and for
some reason all goddamn day I have stuff
to do I don't have time to go to the
post office well thanks to Stan's com
this is deal it's important to look
professional to your clients you don't
look unprofessional you want to look
professional to your clients your
customers and your partners you want to
come off like you know what you're doing
that's what this same with this copy
placing regular stamps on your letters
and packages that won't do the trick
alright you look like some eight year
old you know you little butterfly stamp
so you have a nice day stamps you want
professional professional-looking
metered stamps
right if you want to take your business
to the next level or if you want to
intimidate your grandmother when you
send back her sweater all right take my
advice you stamps.com instead this is
the deal you can buy and print official
US postage using your own computer or
someone else's if they're generous but
your own computer and your printer you
print professional-looking postage
directly onto envelopes labels even
paper plus stamp stamp calm will give
you a digital scale my personal favorite
I love the scale you don't I mean I feel
like I'm doing something illegal but I'm
not you know it's safe
basically you can get an exact postage
for any letter or package the instant
you need it and I can back that up
because I'm sending all my DVDs out and
stick it on a little scale it prints it
out I got my little visor it's
phenomenal endorsement here we go part
two I highly recommend it's calm
actually I do it's easy to use it's
convenient and you can start it right
now alright so if you go to stamps comm
they have a special offer for my
listeners all right
you use my last name burn bu are are for
a no risk trial plus 110 dollar bonus
offer which includes that digital scale
that I'm so fond of and fifty-five
dollars in free postage all right you
can't lose all right so go now go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and you type in Burpee
URR that stamps comm enter ber bu r are
you give fifty five dollars of free
postage and $110 know we're in a digital
scale that's what you do alright and now
look at this we're back to the podcast
thanks by the way for everybody's doing
who's been taking advantage of stamps
calm they've been very happy with the
with you guys doing that stuff alright
can you tell I'm trying to search for
something while I'm talking to you
trying to compliment you as I doing this
alright getting over a broad um 28
minutes in alright we're flying we're
flying now getting over a broad howdy
bill go [ __ ] yourself alright I broke up
with my girlfriend seven months ago
several months ago and I'm having
trouble getting over her we broke up
because I had to move for school I
or to myself I would stop contacting her
because I was becoming psychotic and
jealous and I did I am still finding
myself thinking about her all the time
all of the girls in my new town are
horrific monsters if they aren't
white-trash ugly [ __ ]
they are super hot but brain-dead and
boring and way out of my league dude how
is somebody brain-dead and boring out of
your league
what cuz they're super hot just walk up
to her what is she gonna sell he's all
she gonna do is say no oh not saying
she's gonna say no every time you got it
listen listen let me tell you something
do you want a [ __ ] beautiful girl do
you want to marry a [ __ ] beautiful
woman a beautiful smart woman isn't that
what every guy wants to do well you're
not gonna do it if you're too afraid to
talk to him
alright so why don't you practice on a
brain-dead stupid one
so someday when that girl walks in it
takes your breath away you're gonna have
the [ __ ] balls over there to walk up
you know say something witty why you got
your hand on it no don't do that you
know you know what I'm saying
all right anyways my ex-girlfriend was
smart hot funny cool and was really into
me I tried getting over her by banging
other chicks but it doesn't work it just
leaves them brokenhearted and makes me
feel worse well wait a minute how they
brokenhearted after you just banged him
that means you bang him for a couple of
weeks and then tell him to [ __ ] off
don't do that you you should just be you
know stick and move alright anyways he
says I can't seem to find anyone that
can measure up to my ex need more
solutions alright well you know when you
break up with somebody that you care
about and they have all those good
attributes it's gonna be a while before
you meet another one all right so you
just got to go through it dude if you if
you if you don't wanna get back together
with the other girl you know then what
you got to do is you get you got to
learn to be [ __ ] single again you got
to remember what did i do before I met
that lass
girl what did I do Wow well let's see I
had beers I [ __ ] worked out
I watched football or whatever the [ __ ]
you did I went to one of them went to
the Hunger Games I read that trilogy of
books or whatever the [ __ ] that is you
know it hurts okay
breaking up with somebody who is awesome
but it's just not right or whatever it
hurts so accepted
all right platoon take the pain you know
once you sit down have a good cry just
[ __ ] cry it out of you every day just
wake up think about it but when your
bottom lip starts quivering don't stop
it just give in to it that's what kills
guys we don't cry just [ __ ] cry just
[ __ ] cry put your face in your pillow
and cry like a little [ __ ] girl I
shouldn't have said girl just [ __ ]
cry like a human being why do we deny
that emotion is meant just let it out
alright then wake up you know once
you're done crying go in the bathroom
put your face on go get yourself a bowl
of Froot Loops just you know after you
done curry I'm gonna get through this
you hate yourself up good day today go
hit on some [ __ ] hot brain dead
boring [ __ ] broad it just is practice
just is practice okay you're gonna fight
another one you sound like you're still
young it's not like you have fifty even
then at 50 I swear to God if you're
making money you can probably still get
like a hot 34 year old you know I
wouldn't go any younger than that you
know cuz you got to think by the time
you're sixty she's gonna be 44 she could
still hang in there for that you know
and all you got to do is just keep
[ __ ] spinning her around in the
bedroom for another five years and then
she's too old to give a [ __ ] and then
you got her and she'll be Pat and Pat
you [ __ ] rubbing your forehead as
you're laying there and your deathbed
you know telling you that you did the
right thing you going to younger than
that they have options and they'll leave
you alright so getting over broad that's
what you got to do you got to cry it out
of you and you just gotta accept it's
gonna hurt and it takes time okay but uh
you know though
run back to the other one just cuz
you're lonely alright cuz then you're
gonna have to [ __ ] it you got to break
up with them again you know it's like
[ __ ] Iraq we just did it right the
first time wouldn't had to go back the
second time you know didn't make any
sense all right next one
bill get a gun look buddy look buddy
it's simple get a gun I'm totally
totally gonna be like stereotypically
when I finished when I first started
banging my lawyer I'd stay over a place
almost every night she was still
finishing up her divorce and the ex was
still in DIC mode Jesus Christ I
remember one nights last morning she
woke me up saying she heard something
downstairs she insisted I go down and
look I'd stayed silent pretending I was
just waiting to hear really I was
[ __ ] myself on the inside course you
were nobody wants to go down there and
figure out who the [ __ ] it is all she
had was a pen wait all she had was a pen
that I thought I could nicolas cage into
a neck if i had to butt naked butt naked
I'm walking around scared as hell pen in
hand come up empty and soon enough what
came up empty so every time he didn't
find anybody and soon enough bought it
Taurus PT 140 Pro it's a sidearm I shot
once and keeping in arm's reach of my
bed I'll tell you what mr. burr I sleep
like a baby and I'm relaxed and relaxed
knowing it's there plus it makes you
feel like a man maybe if you start pick
packing heat you'll get off you period
your period and quit bitching about how
bad your podcast sucks
one more thing who is the greatest
American band Creedence Clearwater
Revival first of all dude you [ __ ]
you went out and got a gun you shot it
once and then that's it you don't want
to get good at it actually went shooting
this week I went to the gun range
everybody I shot a five shot 38 and I
shot a
shot a 9-millimeter and I gotta tell you
something it was [ __ ] terrifying at
first and then quickly became awesome
and I enjoyed the entire process
I enjoyed loading it I enjoyed shooting
it the skill of trying to hit the target
on you know taking the shells out of the
five shot and you know they let me clean
it I would have loved it I was like
[ __ ] private Pyle in Full Metal
Jacket by the end of it [ __ ] looking
down up through my eyebrows I completely
enjoyed it but you don't sound like you
respect it sir you sound like the kind
of guy who shouldn't have a gun if you
asked me you shot it once and I keeping
an arm reach of your bed and now you
[ __ ] sleep like a baby because I know
it stay and I'll just [ __ ] waving
around then you don't we gotta watch out
with a gun is it's an instant black belt
that's the thing and you didn't go
through the discipline of it so you
gotta respect the fact that you could
[ __ ] kill somebody I know the guy
right I'm just saying this right now so
this guy can [ __ ] go to the gun range
tomorrow and put like a red wig on his
targets and start [ __ ] shooting at it
that's the thing about a gun it's this
amazing power when you have it it's
amazing power that you have to [ __ ] I
don't know that's what I felt when I had
it I was just like you have this thing
you have the ability to take a [ __ ]
life and it was like really like you
know I didn't get this psycho charge
from it I felt like this ridiculous
level of responsibility like I was
holding a baby near an alligator or some
[ __ ] if that makes any [ __ ] sense
it's the people who [ __ ] get those
gets you know it's like people will get
pit bulls and they treat them nice and
then other people who get pit bulls and
they try to make turn the dog into the
badass they never were you don't I mean
you're kind of coming off like that why
the [ __ ] would you only shoot it once
and then you keep it loaded by the side
of your bed you know I I got like three
or four different contacts and I'm gonna
like serious gun safety courses that I'm
gonna take and whatever gun I get I'm
gonna know how to [ __ ] take that
thing apart put it
back together everything about it go to
the gun range a zillion times
so I'm proficient with the [ __ ]
weapon and and then you know keep it in
a safe goddamn place where no one can
get hurt with it and if somebody [ __ ]
with me I could instantly get it you
know
that's my deal I'm not gonna shoot it
once and then keep it by my bed I
[ __ ] feel safe now man why don't you
get off your period why is that what you
talking all tough now cuz you got your
gun how come you didn't talk [ __ ] about
my podcast before what cuz you were
unarmed huh I'm gonna push this guy over
the edge anyways he says who's your
foods that is the greatest American band
[ __ ] Aerosmith Creedence Clearwater
Revival you don't think all their songs
sound the same Oh beer Nero when I was
just a little boy something about a
swamp even though we're all from
Sacramento the [ __ ] don't make no sense
all Susak you wellactually like Koreans
Clearwater Revival but my brother when I
was a kid he bought like the [ __ ]
eight Cosette Greatest Hits thing that
I'm sure their manager put out from that
song things Kate did but he'll steal
your buddy he put it he put that [ __ ]
out I'm sure he got all the [ __ ]
money and my brother listened to those
things over and over and over and over
again and it got to the point I [ __ ]
I hated the band but it's been 20 years
since I've listened to him and every
once in a while I hear when I'm starting
to like him again it's kind of Led
Zeppelin Led Zeppelin I listen to every
you know how overplayed stairway to
heaven is I did that to every one of
their songs and yeah it became like when
I started here in Led Zeppelin it was
like you know that moment in Clockwork
Orange when they're holding his [ __ ]
eyes open and he starts to get sick when
he sees violence like I would get like
nauseous when I heard him I would say
Aerosmith you know is that right
I don't know I'm [ __ ] old I like
Aerosmith we're making [ __ ] albums -
what 40 goddamn years
doesn't that count for something ccr7 37
Coleman out of this guy
huh you know it separately from
Sacramento how come they never said
hella and any of their songs anybody
tell me that anybody explain that to me
the [ __ ] am I talking about alright
let's get to some more advertising here
people we're going to Gamefly right now
gamefly.com everybody do you play video
games sure we all do you know what be
awesome what have you got a 15 free 15
day free trial and you get eight
thousand video games delivered to your
home or straight to your PC wouldn't
that be awesome just go-to gamefly.com
slash per 15 days for free 8000 games at
your fingertips either delivered to your
door or straight to your damn PC you
can't do any better than that all right
so there's your fix if you got video
games thanks to the Monday morning
podcast look at me
you got a post office in your house you
got 8000 games now right you go to skate
you go to skate fenders calm you're
protecting your feet and I don't know
what else I got to do for you people
this guy still [ __ ] bitching at me
old tough guy there with this [ __ ]
gun oh I got a gun now now I'm gonna
talk [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] they should give me a BB
gun um all right overrated underrated
for this week underrated t-tops on a
Pontiac Firebird it's my childhood right
there because nothing beats getting can
you guys proof proofread your [ __ ] Oh
getting dome okay because I'm sorry this
one's on me because nothing beats
getting dome in your parked car while
you get to look at the stars he says
it's one of the most awesome things
you'll get to experience wow dude you
know what you just painted a picture I
think I got a I gotta add that to my
bucket list and you know what - you
can't you can't be like just
on the street you can't hear the sound
of the street you got to go to someplace
secluded right on a [ __ ] moonlit
night have some chick blow you Matt's
you know she'd probably actually think
that that was romantic you listen and
that whole thing is a unicorn all right
overrated imports imports I'm referring
to all the Japanese burners you see on
the streets the Honda Civics the Acura
Integra is the Nissan 240sx everybody
thinks they they they're the [ __ ] and
they want to race them when in reality
they wouldn't stand a chance against
good ol American Muscle what are your
thoughts uh I don't know that I know
enough about racing though it doesn't
this Honda do all right in Formula One I
know it's all German right Mercedes and
obviously Ferrari does great well I
guess this is the deal when I think of
high-speed performance I think of
Porsche Porsche is all over the [ __ ] you
supposed to say it
Lamborghinis all the Italian and German
[ __ ] that's what I think about Maseratis
you know and when I think of you want a
[ __ ] lot of up you want a race man
you want to go [ __ ] you want to get
sunk into your seat and go on a straight
line as fast as you can [ __ ] can then
then I think American cars you know what
I mean who's kidding who our cars can't
corner not cuz we're stupid it's just we
don't need to corner cuz we have land
over here we're not like those [ __ ]
countries and over in Europe where they
just everyone's the size of [ __ ]
Rhode Island so there's a lot of turns
and you know and not to mention they
made the [ __ ] roads you know back
when they were [ __ ] bring an ox into
town and [ __ ] hairpin [ __ ] turns you
watch the Tour de France those [ __ ]
guys and the bicycles they can't even
make the [ __ ] turns over there so
because of that because of that handicap
I think that they actually make they
make better cars than us but as far as
the Japanese stuff I think the Japanese
you know I don't have an original
opinion about it but I think they took
what we were doing you know we took a
lot from the Europeans and then they
took what we were doing and they just
didn't they improved it I'll stop
rolling your [ __ ] eyes you know what
I'm talking about
if you change
the oil on a Toyota or a Honda that
[ __ ] every three to three thousand
miles that [ __ ] thing is gonna it's
gonna you get eight hundred thousand
miles out of it all right
and I know American cars have made a
comeback but you gotta understand I am a
scarred child of the 80s and in the
[ __ ] late 70s right through the 80s
they made American cars there was a
corporate decision they made him so they
would self-destruct sixty to eighty
thousand miles in you know I'm telling
you they just the [ __ ] transmission
would drop out and it was done on
purpose terrible I still think that the
American auto industry is trying to
recover from that
despite the fact that they now have ten
year 100,000 mile warranties I don't
know that's that that's my [ __ ]
thoughts all right I like I like some of
the Japanese stuff you know justice for
me I got a [ __ ] Toyota Prius I love
that goddamn car I love it I don't care
the people call me a [ __ ] when I'm
driving it you know I'm still
comfortable with me what's the [ __ ] I
filled it up with gas today thirty five
bucks go [ __ ] yourself all right
go [ __ ] yourself also filled up my truck
and that cost me 65 for three-quarters
of a tank underrated going to a hockey
game early and watching warmups there's
no one around you you will there's no
one around you with dumb foam fingers or
micro web drink micro brew drinking
brothers I can't even [ __ ] read this
week plus you can watch all the players
[ __ ] off and try cool [ __ ] all the while
trying to snipe on the backup goalie
yeah that's actually true you guys been
watching the NHL playoffs playoffs I've
been watching on the Bruins capitals
that's like a great pitcher's duel
except it's the goalies both games have
gone into overtime but I've also been
watching the first the Penguins and I
have a weird sports relationship with
both of those teams in Pittsburgh I like
the Penguins fans I hate their [ __ ]
team
I hate him alright then what like I
think the Rangers coach summed them up
and shouldn't have been fined he should
have been given an award all right
they're [ __ ] filthy goddamn team and
anybody does anything to them they
[ __ ] [ __ ] moan and clean you saw what
the [ __ ] they did today I thought it was
the filthy Flyers look at the Penguins
getting all mad down three games to none
they start [ __ ] cross-checking people
in their throats right
just [ __ ] doing all kinds of
reprehensible [ __ ]
III don't you know I totally respect
that franchise because they their
ability to go from you know Mario
Lemieux and Jaromir Jagr and within 20
years to have another one-two punch
Crosby and Malkin is you know and Jordan
Staal I mean that they're [ __ ] there
this [ __ ] tremendous [ __ ] franchise
but I don't I don't like you know I
don't know they always seem to have
those guys that really like to go after
people's [ __ ] nice you know then you
got a [ __ ] paulie pouty lips their
[ __ ] moaning and complaining you see
him trying to fight not throwing a punch
not throwing a punch not throwing a
punch and then in comes the ref then he
starts throwing a [ __ ] punch and at
the end of the game when there's no ref
around the guy wanted to go he wouldn't
go but the [ __ ] either fight or don't
run your yep all right and then the
Flyers
I love the Flyers but I hate their
[ __ ] feds I don't like the offense
[Laughter]
and out of they don't like the offense
yeah I told you the deal went to a
Bruins game with my mom up in Boston
there was flier fans behind me and they
were crass and they ruined it my mother
was then it was just [ __ ] they're just
[ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] but I love
that team so I've been watching that
series and it's it's just been [ __ ] I
don't know I know it's been difficult
but uh what do you would've the flyer
fans think what do you guys think you
think this is here you're gonna win your
cup anyone I think your weaknesses I
think it's your [ __ ] goalie with his
weird colored pads I know you're up
three games to none against the Penguins
but I have you noticed that your goalie
has given up 12 goals in three games
that's not a good that's not a good
thing averaging giving up four goals
again you know if the [ __ ] Penguins
goalie wasn't I don't know what the [ __ ]
he looks like he's playing twister every
time they come down he's [ __ ] got his
he's on all fours with his arms crossed
I don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing is
the puck he's like trying to like she's
playing like whack-a-mole with the
goddamn puck and I'm watching I'm
missing it right now I'm watching the
Kings Vancouver which was zero zero when
I came downstairs loving the Kings
loving the Kings beating the Vancouver
Canucks loving him you know it's another
team flopping all over the goddamn ice
Jesus Christ if any NHL player listens
to this [ __ ] I swear to god they're
either gonna hug me or [ __ ] punch me
in the face depending depending on who
you play for this is what the Bruins
don't win it ah who would I like to see
I would say the LA Kings but I just know
some LA Kings fans are also Laker fans
and I wish them no happiness whatsoever
so it would be hard even though I like
the Kings I think I think I'd have to
say the I like the st. Louis Blues just
cuz they've never won a [ __ ] Stanley
Cup they almost had the Presidents
Trophy but I mean I just I just like
they
I went to I went to a game when I was in
st. Louis and they have real they got
real fans old-school hardcore [ __ ]
fans like a lot of those teams in the
North even though they're the old field
Norris it's weird I like I like st.
Louis and I like Chicago which I know is
sacrilegious if you live in either one
of those cities but I just like both
teams there I [ __ ] said it and I used
to like Vancouver until last year when
we played him in the finals and they
would just you know flip flopping all
over the [ __ ] ice you know the earth
you know but that's that's called a
sport over in Europe it's called a
beautiful game you know when you I don't
know you you cheat in an effeminate
manner you know that's what you guys are
bringing to the table
I mean I'll admit that with fat and
stupid over here we don't read can you
guys at least admit that you're [ __ ]
a bunch of flopping [ __ ] over there
overrated China China is overrated all
right I spent last summer dude if it
wasn't for China I wouldn't be able to
[ __ ] look at this laptop right now is
that what they make them I don't know I
just like bitching about [ __ ] and not
really finding out what's going on 51
minutes in baby I spent last summer in
China studying law and staring at the
top of blackheads from my 6-3 viewpoint
the Chinese are an incredibly diverse
culture in all that when compared to us
Americans but many if not all am I gonna
start reading some racist [ __ ] this
already okay let's just go slow here the
Chinese are an incredibly diverse
culture and all that when compared to us
Americans doesn't that just sound like
the opening of something racist you know
they're really diverse and all that
stuff and junk and all that stuff but
you know but many if not all of those
differences are precisely what makes
America what
but many if not all of the all those
differences are precisely what America
makes America so for lack of a better
word oh so bad friggin ass
Chinese are incredibly diverse culture i
canti what the [ __ ] is he saying so that
was you just said that they're a diverse
culture and all that when compared to us
and then you started saying that now
what we're diverse I don't understand
what you saying here he said they're
their food
I guess Chinese food could not be
anything close to what any sensible
human being could call decent you don't
get I don't know what the word is P way
or none of that in China you get some
nasty noodles or even the nice
restaurants paired up with the whole
fish eyes and all and mind you this is
this is breakfast lunch and dinner we're
talking I won't even go into the dog
issue see attached photo what I'm not
looking at the attached photo we really
got a dog hanging from a [ __ ] hook in
a window anyways when I got back to the
States the first place I went was in and
out for a six by six not kidding I don't
know what that means and I nearly
chalked it chalked it up and snorted it
Oh chop it up and snorted it you wrote
chalked noodles will never be the same
for that [ __ ] you China come on dude I
don't want to be trashed in China like
this the cities are filthy Beijing all
right he didn't have a good time over
there most important the people are
a-holes not all of them maybe not think
did I call it or what the government
doesn't give a flying [ __ ] about them so
they figure hey why not be an [ __ ]
right is this what these just what they
said to you or this is what you sort of
I mean to say that the government
doesn't give a [ __ ] about them it is
really just sort of you kind of skimming
the surface there I don't think I don't
think underneath an oppressive any cold
regime over there they have that weird
thing will they have all like this
technology and iPhones and iPads mean
[ __ ] they build them right the
cellphones are actually better than ours
yet if you
say anything about their Fuhrer don't
doesn't like they run over you in it
with a good tank sorry I'm just piecing
together clips I've seen in CNN for the
last 20 [ __ ] years so he tells me
some story uh-oh he's saying Barry
Sanders couldn't get through a crowd
without getting bruised up without
getting a bruised rib I'm on a packed
subway one night and this [ __ ] behind
me is digging his scrawny little elbow
into my kidneys I'm ready to turn around
and rabbit punch the [ __ ] when I
get off and I finally get room to take a
full breath and actually turn around
it's this little friggin old lady with a
shit-eating grin on her face
I was so close bill yeah you know
thought I was getting on a flight one
time and somebody was elbowing me in the
back and I turn around and it was I
believe a little Chinese woman but you
got an understanding it's so jam-packed
over there that's just part of their
culture they're not being dicks
that's just like them beep in a horn I
think so yeah don't don't punch an old
lady in the face early underrated
manners now that I'm talking about Buffy
and banging at the country not that I'm
talking about Buffy and Baggins at the
Country Club type [ __ ] I'm talking about
the friendly pardon means excuse me oops
my bad etc there's none of that [ __ ]
maybe I was unlucky or the fact that I'm
a huge American guy they treated me
particularly awful but at the end of the
day I was so aggravated by the repeated
Nuggets
spitting in my path burping within a few
feet of me that I took everything for me
not to pounce it at least one on one
person daily yeah dude I mean you're
dealing with a different culture over
there I mean it well there's six [ __ ]
billion seven billion people on the
planet and I think like they have over a
billion of them there so I don't know I
think you just sort of missed America
you know we all got our [ __ ] this
there's good stuff and bad stuff I don't
I don't I don't be trash in China okay
all right I already feel guilty enough
that I bought this goddamn laptop even
though I knew what the [ __ ] those people
are going through over there to put them
together you know are you guys honestly
telling me that's the only way that you
can that they can keep this thing you
know for the price that it is
can't like the CEOs make a little bit
less money when you get to that level
you know you know what I love about the
sociopaths in the corporate world they
always just have all the prizes let the
market will bear the market will bear it
but you know and just completely
removing themselves I don't know I have
such [ __ ] hatred for that and all the
way the other side you know neo was
making dinner tonight right cuz she's a
[ __ ] angel absolute angel
right she's making me this awesome meal
and she needed this right so she goes
can you go trainees Jones he goes Trader
Joe's and get some jasmine rice and I
like abso-fucking-lutely right so I jump
in the Prius and I Drive over to [ __ ]
Trader Joe's okay and I got out and I
got to tell you something man
maybe cuz it was I don't know they level
a douchebag in a Trader Joe's like if
you ever just wanted to rid the world of
douchebags yeah I would start at Trader
Joe's you know what maybe it's just an
LA thing I went in there and just every
[ __ ] you know what it look like it
looked like a bunch of rich kids trying
to dress like they were poor every one
of them was just [ __ ] annoying with
their ridiculously on purpose ugly way
of dressing just each one of them just
trying to be more and more out of style
hey man I don't even know what since
that whole [ __ ] hipster thing awful
you know thank God I showed up like I'm
not a douchebag
you know I think that they look at me
just the way I dress like they think I'm
some frat boy date rapist you know just
because I have I look like I could
actually catch a ball I don't know I
don't know look at me trying to paint
myself like I'm the bad ass at the
Trader Joe's you know what I think I
think we've I think I've had about
enough of this podcast her this week I
have an early early call time tomorrow
everybody all right so what do I say now
what do I say now Oh amazon.com everyone
you want to
to the podcast and support the troops
here's how you can do it all right
anytime you go into amazon.com
rather than just going directly to
amazon.com you know just swing by Bill
burr calm click on the podcast page and
then click on the amazon banner on the
right hand side of the podcast page and
I know what you're thinking well Jesus
bill that's [ __ ] two extra steps well
you know what it is two extra steps but
listen to what you'll be doing you'll go
to amazon.com you don't have to do
anything else if you buy something not
saying you have to but if you do I get a
kickback on that and then I take 10% of
the kickback and I give it to the troops
what do you think about that so you can
[ __ ] support my podcast and the
troops the Wounded Warriors Project all
at the same time don't you think that's
worth two extra steps come on you know
you did something bad this week we all
did don't you need a little bit of good
karma you know just something someday
after you die and you stand in there in
front of OJ Gina's dad and you'd be like
well you know I went to Bill burrs
podcast and uh you know actually don't
say my name that's probably not a good
thing to do up there
uh you know I [ __ ] donate it to uh
the Wounded Warriors Project you know
all right that's it I've had enough have
you had enough I hope you enjoyed this
podcast as much as I did I had a really
good time I enjoyed myself you know what
it turned me on
I got a wah-wah pedal I am so close to I
am so close to a level of [ __ ] awful
on the guitar you know you know you know
I'm saying like you have to be like a
certain level of awful you just can't be
completely [ __ ] awful what just make
somebody turn their head I'm at a level
I'm almost at that level where it's
actually listenable and it'll be
hilarious so if you guys ed me on I'm
learning how to solo in a in a minor
alright I'll [ __ ] around with my wah-wah
pedal maybe sing you some tunes ha well
that'd fill up your [ __ ] days
while you're waiting for somebody to
change your life for the love your life
to walk in through the door right if
you're sitting there going oh I don't
know who to talk to this is what I want
you to you know be great for all of your
souls today why don't you get up put
your head like halfway over your [ __ ]
cubicle wall never sitting next to you
just go hey hey when they look at you be
like [ __ ] give him the finger [ __ ]
you what was that for you know because
every time I look at you you remind me
of what I've also accepted you know what
the [ __ ] it means having an office with
walls that don't reach the ceiling
without a [ __ ] door you know what I'm
talking about right you lock in with her
you speak passionately next thing you
know next thing you know you're banging
her maybe you act like you're working
late and you go in and you're [ __ ]
fornicator on your boss's desk not
realizing that he has 24 hours security
and it's being recorded by some [ __ ]
fat [ __ ] who's supposed to be a security
guard and rather than going in there and
stopping it he decides to record it so
he can put it on his YouTube page and
maybe get some hits maybe we can talk
about it loudly in a bar and be like oh
I was the guy who uploaded it you know
and then some pathetic girl whose dad
took off when he was when she was three
years old will overhear that and
actually blow that guy see that it's
called the winds of change right there
when a butterfly flaps its [ __ ] wings
Jesus all right that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves and I mean
that too from the bottom of my heart
each and every one of you can go [ __ ]
yourselves this week and don't take any
[ __ ] and I just just this week well you
know what you do why don't you guys
start sabotaging those cubicle [ __ ]
walls just every week just take us one
screw-up you know what you do is start
far away from your cubicle at first so
no one suspects you and then once they
start getting wise take one out near you
cuz why would you do that right your
cubicle why would you leave that
evidence right near you you like Sharon
Stone
you know then you wear Larry Bird shorts
with no underwear underneath it you then
you uncross and then cross your legs
flashing a little ball back when they
interrogate you and that's how you get
out of it that's how she did it right in
the end she still had the ice pick under
the bed all right that's it
I got nothing else hey hey you [ __ ]
April 27th I'm gonna be at Concord
College in Concord New Hampshire and
unlike most the college gigs I do this
one is actually open to the public so if
you were too stupid to get in that
school you know and you [ __ ] plow the
streets and get hammered afterwards
wearing your high school football jacket
you always wondered what [ __ ] college
was like why don't you come on down to
Concord college in Concord New Hampshire
on [ __ ] April 27th and I will be
there telling my jokes all right have a
good day
you